مع أوكرانيا تستخدم الآن الذخائر العنقودية التي زودتها بها الولايات المتحدة
لمحاولة اختراق
مواقع الجيش الروسي الراسخة
على الجبهة الجنوبية. الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين يهاجم الولايات المتحدة
وحلفائها لمساعدة كييف،
يمكن للعالم كله أن يرى أن
المعدات التي يفترض أنها غير معرضة للخطر والتي
يتباهى بها الغرب  إنها مشتعلة ومن
الناحية الفنية غالبًا ما تكون أدنى من
بعض الأسلحة السوفيتية الصنع، نعم بالطبع
يمكن توفير أسلحة غربية إضافية
وإلقائها في المعركة، وهذا بالطبع
يسبب لنا أضرارًا معينة
ويطيل أمد الصراع، لكن بينما
يحاول بوتين إظهار التفوق في
ساحة المعركة  في الداخل،
يواصل الكرملين إسكات الأصوات المنتقدة،
حتى بعض أولئك الذين يدعمون حربهم،
المدون العسكري البارز إيغور جيركين،
والذي يعرف أيضًا باسم إيجور ستريلكوف، الذي اعتقل
اليوم زوجته بعد تصريحات
انتقدت فيها عدم إحراز تقدم في
الحملة العسكرية الروسية في أوكرانيا،
مع الوضع العسكري الخاص.
العملية وفي البلاد بشكل عام أمر
مؤسف بعبارة ملطفة، قال إن
هذا نتيجة تصرفات
السلطة الحالية. جيركين هو
عقيد سابق في جهاز الأمن الروسي FSB
وكان وزير الدفاع
فيما يسمى بجمهورية دوناتس الشعبية في
الشرق  أوكرانيا عندما
أسقطت الطائرة الماليزية mh-17 هناك في عام
2014. وأدانت
محكمة هولندية جيركين غيابيًا بارتكاب جريمة قتل جماعي لتورطه
في الحادث الذي
لم يعترف به مطلقًا بينما يعتبر جيركين
مجرم حرب في أوكرانيا الذي
يعتبره نفسه.
قومي روسي متطرف يشعر بأنه
يجب محاكمة الحرب بشكل أكثر وحشية، وقد تم
تحدي قبضة بوتين على السلطة مؤخرًا من خلال انتفاضة
شركة فاغنر العسكرية الخاصة ورئيسها
يفغيني بريجوسيان،
والآن يريد الزعيم الروسي تهدئة
الأمور مدير وكالة المخابرات المركزية ويليام بيرنز.
يعتقد أن بوتين يحاول شراء الوقت الذي أراه
يعتبر ما يجب فعله مع فاغنر وما يجب
فعله مع البورجوسي نفسه،
كما تعلم، يكره بوتين في تجربتي
على أي حال الصورة التي يبالغ فيها في رد فعله
تجاه الأشياء ولكن هذا لا يعني
الإيقاع، هل يغفر بيرن يقول إذا كنت
لو كنت باغوسانًا فلن أطرد متذوق طعامي